[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview notre
invité le dr thierno baldé chef de
l'unité partenariats opérationnels au
bureau régional de l oms afrique située
à brazzaville au congo
bonjour docteur belle des merci de nous
accorder cet entretien pour faire le
point sur la pandémie en afrique
bonjour pour commencer à dr bell des
landes est submergé par à la pandémie à
cause d'un nouveau variant mais aussi
des rassemblements de masse à la
directrice régionale de l' oms afrique
dit craindre un scénario à l'indienne en
afrique
pourquoi le risque est élevé oui ben oui
absolument on suit avec beaucoup de
visibilité donc la suggestion qui se
passe en inde actuellement et ça nous
préoccupe beaucoup parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de facteurs de risque ici dans
notre région qui nous amène donc à
devoir augmenter les capacités vraiment
de préparation pour éviter une situation
similaire par rapport à ce qui se passe
en inde actuelle hormis se faire
vacciner c'est pas évident quand même
faute de doses on va y revenir tout à
l'heure longuement sur la vaccination et
pour éviter ce scénario indien quelles
sont les recommandations de l oms
afrique
bon évidemment il s'agit d'un engagement
important donc des différentes
communautés des différentes populations
pour pouvoir adhérer aux différentes
mesures de santé publique les mesures
barrières ça c'est quelque chose
d'absolument important il s'agit aussi
d'augmenter véritablement les capacités
vraiment de prise en charge médicale
pour les patients qui peuvent tomber
gravement malade donc ça c'est quelque
chose d'important
il s'agit d'augmenter vraiment toute la
surveillance la capacité de comprendre
la dynamique de transmission donc de
l'épidémie dans tous les différents pays
donc de la région sauf des éléments tous
ces éléments qui mises ensemble qu'ils
noueraient pourrait nous permettre
véritablement d'éviter vraiment cette
catastrophe allez les chiffres en tout
cas du centre de contrôle et de
prévention des maladies du continent
l'afrique ac dc qui dépend
de l'union africaine sont plus tombons
3,1 pour cent des cas environ 4 % de
décès vous allez nous confirmer cela
comment le continent résiste-t-il à la
pandémie
oui jusqu'à maintenant un corps selon
les chiffres que nous corrigions de
façon très très régulière avec les
guidons de la région ici on est autour
toujours de 2 % donc de du pourcentage
général donc des personnes affectées par
là que vit dans le monde entier
autant en terme de nombre donc totale
quand nombre donc aussi de décès donc
c'est quelque chose quand même d'assez
et réconfortante assez satisfaisant de
nombreux efforts mis en place donc par
les différents états membres avec
l'appui de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé des autres organisations comme le
site is it africains donc pour pouvoir
vraiment avoir cette préparation
optimale pour donc riposté à cette
attaque
l'épidémie a commencé à bientôt
maintenant un peu plus d'un an dans
notre région mais on voit comme on l'a
dit donc des chiffres qui sont
relativement stables d'où vous donner
quelques indications autour de la
semaine dernière à sur l'entièreté du
continent du continent africain on parle
d'environ cinquante mille cas qui ont
été enregistrés donc ça c'est une
situation stable nous sommes observés
dans tous les différents pays bon avec
quelques variantes
maintenant il faudrait toujours la même
on commence à observer d'essence décade
avec beaucoup d'attention avec les
différents pays que l'on puisse donc
anticiper donc des conséquences néfastes
que l'on ne voudrait pas voir dans notre
région les 13 pays
quelles sont ces 13 pays bon il faut se
dire que il s'agit par exemple des pays
a pas marre quand on dit que puis par
exemple l'afrique du sud le kenya le
cameroun donc c'est un pays
véritablement parce que c'est une
situation qui fluctuent en ce moment
c'est ce que nous observons mais c'est
des choses qui fluctuent donc c'est une
dynamique vraiment assez évolutive
mais ces pays-là contenu de beaucoup
d'éléments donc on observe actuellement
cette fuite d'essence l'a par exemple le
kenyan comprendre a dit tout à l'heure
il ya des pays aussi comme ça il ya
d'autres tout cela on observe tout cela
et c'est une tendance vraiment chang'an
pour figurer
filmé yeux auparavant c'était d'autres
pays aussi mentionner un peu qui
rapportait ce plutôt qu'à des actions
ont été mises en place actuellement dans
la mique actuellement ce sont ces 13
pays
mais il n'y a pas de focus match suivant
cette place là de façon à celle exigée
alors il ya une bonne résilience mais
vous l'avez dit le continent est quand
même été touché par une deuxième vague
de contamination probablement lié vous
allez nous confirmer ou varions sud
africain qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous
dire sur l'évolution justement de ce
variant sur le continent oui absolument
je crois que c'est vrai qu'il ya le
valliamé aussi a aussi sur leur fatigue
aussi des communautés des populations
par rapport à la décision de ces mesures
de santé publique là qui sont très très
importante donc savez ici les conditions
socio-économiques donc de nos
populations ici donc ne sont pas si
évidentes
donc il s'agit donc de pouvoir
encourager ces différentes populations à
continuer cette adhésion à ces mesures
barrières donc ce qui n'est pas
nécessairement le cas on observe en
afrique on observe un peu dans toutes
les autres régions du monde
maintenant on pourrait venir la pause en
tuf alliance sud africain c'est sûr que
cela a affecté notamment après l'afrique
du sud
il ya certes est incertaine quant au
point il ya les pays limitrophes aussi
de l'afrique du sud dont les pays de
l'afrique australe aussi qu'ils ont
essayé affecté aussi par ce variant là
mais il ya eu des actions fortes et
énergie qui ont été en place donc dans
cette vaccination la contourner en train
de parler actuellement donc qui évolue
qui permet donc à voir cette situation
qui est relativement stable et
relativement sous contrôle pour le
moment donc à la mède et je pense qu'il
est important de mentionner parce que
les mouvements pendant l'entre-deux
certains pays de l'afrique de l'est sont
assez importants donc il faut vraiment
garder un oeil une attention
particulière à ces pays il avait
continué la surveillance c'est vrai il
ya ce variant indien qui inquiète le
monde entier il ya le varions
britannique aussi le variant brésilien
est ce que ces derniers variant sont
également présents sur le continent
et comment si oui comment les
populations réagi
à ces contaminations au niveau
immunitaire oui mais il n'y a pas de
données extrêmement robuste vous savez
que la recherche est limitée de ce côté
ci mais mais mais pour le moment on sait
que ces variables ont été observées dans
de nombreux pays mais pas dans la
proportion que l'on attend que l'on a vu
dans d'autres pays il ya des études
donnent de sirop de sureau prévalence
qui sont actuellement de grands courts
pour comprendre un peu vraiment la
nature des virus qui a fait du virus
dont qui affectent certaines populations
actuellement on est ces études là sont
en cours actuellement mais on ne peut
pas dire avec exactitude aujourd'hui la
magnitude ou encore là vraiment l'impact
de ce virus là dans ces différents pays
là par contre on sait qu'ils sont
présents qu'il circule dans une moindre
échelle
et puis donc mais une fois de plus pour
le moment on n'a pas un peu cette grande
à cette grande amie conséquences
véritablement de c2c de ces variants là
dans nos pays de la région et au niveau
de la contagiosité
comment les classer tous ces variants
que le variant sud africain on est
toujours en train d'apprendre un peu de
ses différents varial là on sait que
leur transmissibilité un peu plus
importante elle est beaucoup plus
importante par rapport aux autres
variantes mais pour le moment donc les
études au niveau mondial au niveau
global ou pour les déterminer
un peu plus davantage voire un peu s'il
ya des ajustements un peu on a affaire
aux niveaux donc que ce soit des vaccins
ou bien au niveau des protocoles de
prise en charge mais c'est des choses
qui sont très dynamiques qui sont très
très changeante et que la chose la plus
importante c'est de pouvoir avoir dans
ce système de surveillance là ce système
de prise en charge la qui est
relativement prêt à aborder donc adressé
un peu c'est problématique là qui sont
nouvelles et qui ne sont pas
nécessairement attendus et les
informations dont vous disposez
concernant ce variant indien est ce
qu'il est plus contagieux voire même
plus virulent que le sud africain où le
brésilien sait que l'on a vu évidemment
en n2 vous le conviendrez avec moi
effectivement il a des conséquences
assez néfaste actuellement et donc oui
on aille à des préoccupations très très
très important donc de ce côté ci a
maintenant il ya beaucoup de facteurs
qui interviennent donc dans
dans les conséquences et un peu où
l'effet de ces virus la danse / sur les
personnes donc ça ça risque encore
d'être donc on a vu cette situation au
niveau de leur cancer at il ici au
niveau de la région
ça c'est une autre question mais cela
cela étant dit il faut véritablement se
préparer pour pouvoir répondre de façon
efficace et effective donc à ces
nouveaux variants indien les prévisions
de l'om est ce justement est ce que
l'afrique va se montrer résiliente face
à cette troisième vague annoncée avec le
vario indien ou alors elle ne pourra pas
hésité vous savez il est un peu
difficile de donner une position très
très claire par rapport à cela quand on
voit un peu l'évolution de toute cette
situation depuis le début de l'épidémie
on avait on avait des prédictions
extrêmement folle donc au niveau de deux
des conséquences donc au niveau donc de
l'afrique a pour le moment on n'a pas
encore vu en cause et conséquence la
donc tenant compte de beaucoup de
facteurs
évidemment les choses peuvent changer
mais une fois de plus la chose la plus
importante le message le plus important
à passer ici parce que ça il s'agit
d'une lutte véritablement commune a non
seulement non seulement avec les publics
avec les communautés les populations
mais aussi les états membres c'est de
préparer tout le monde à pouvoir faire
face aux situations les plus difficiles
donc être prêt pouvoir surveiller
pouvoir mettre en place des systèmes
dans les structures hospitalières
mobiliser du personnel qui peut répondre
à ça à cette tendance là ces nouvelles
tendances sont des éléments qui sont
très importants et que nous encourageons
les gens à prendre dans une étude les
scientifiques y ont découvert le variant
sud africain affirme que les personnes
qui sont contaminées par cette souche
dispose d'une meilleure immunité face
aux autres mutations du coc u19
est ce que le ms a pris en compte cette
étude c'est des études les études de
varie beaucoup actuellement donc oui on
est on est au courant de ces différentes
études là d'autres études aussi sont en
cours pour comprendre un peu toute
l'humanité acquises à la fin de la
ans mission de ces maladies là c'est
quelque chose qui valait beaucoup pour
certains ça peut aller de quelques
semaines à quelques mois
ah mais pour le moment il est un peu
difficile donc de donner une information
plus que précise par rapport donc à la
l'humanité acquise à la suite de la trad
de l'infection donc de cette maladie là
par les populations
mais c'est des éléments je pense qu'ils
méritent une fois de plus dans le choeur
de pouvoir a initié beaucoup d'actions
de recherche donc vous pouvoir vraiment
informé comme il faut ça nous amène
justement la vaccination c'est la
recherche scientifique fond d'un vaccin
à partir de la souche sud africaine
alors il y aura un espoir donc ils
protègent contre les autres variantes
oui actuellement évidemment il ya
pratiquement une cinquantaine de
candidats vaccins qu'on appelle qui sont
en train d'être analysé qui sont en
train d'être évalués de par le monde
entier
et comme vous le savez l'om est dans son
rôle normatif et régulateurs
actuellement il ya quoi il ya trois donc
il ya trois vaccins qui ont été
homologuées dont selon les procédures
d'urgence donc de l' oms il s'agit donc
du vaccin father le vaccin dont
astrazeneca et puis le vaccin gmt donc
actuellement ce sont ceux là qui sont
pour l'ogc et qu'ils ont été évalués
homologué parle mais ce n'est pas qu'il
ya beaucoup d'autres candidats vaccins
et selon les dernières informations que
nous avons il ya d'autres vaccins donc
qui devrait être normalement aussi une
décision devrait être prise dans les dix
au cours des prochains jours il s'agit
donc des vaccins de sitôt pharma et puis
les vaccins aussi sinovac pour comme le
vaccin anti moderne en maintenant le
vaccin sud africain le candidat-vaccin
sud africain les études sont en cours et
donc évidemment l'om et c'est là pour
accompagner toutes ces organisations la
tous ces pays là pour pouvoir avoir
vraiment où le processus d'évaluation
exhaustif pour être sûr que les produits
que l'on a donc pour en permettre
vraiment aux populations de se protéger
contre ce virus là
[Musique]
thierno baldé vous êtes chef de l'unité
partenariats opérationnels au bureau
régional de l'om est-ce afrique le vario
sud africain qui a été identifié fin
2020 c'est vrai qu'il a alimenté la
deuxième vague plus virulente sur le
continent que l'on évoqué tout à l'heure
il a aussi retardé on imagine la
vaccination comment évolue-t-elle
maintenant mais écoutez cette
vaccination là vous savez les ailes ça
puisque une fois de plus sur beaucoup
sur ses vaccins dont on vient de parler
mais également dans le sud de nombreux
accords aussi bilatéraux et
multinationaux et multilatéraux plutôt
donc donc effectivement donc il ya eu ce
fait là un peu à la vaccination mais
cette vaccination l'arrivée à répandre
donc dans une afrique du sud est
actuellement par exemple avec avec les
dernières informations comme la sur le
bac c'est johnson and johnson dont
l'interdiction a été levée par les états
unis donc à des transferts un peu de
savoir cela devrait arriver assez
rapidement en afrique du sud et
l'afrique du sud aussi c'est un pays qui
a c'est qui qui est assez bien organisé
donc les activités de vaccination sont
en cours elle continue comme ça se fait
aussi dans tous les autres pays donc de
la région pour vous donner peut-être
juste quelques informations il ya des
millions de doses de vaccins qui ont été
jusqu'à par exemple ça veut distribuer
dans les différents pays donc de la
région par nom se passe pas en afrique
du sud mais dans de nombreux autres pays
de la région dont cette vaccination
l'aller où elle continue à tuer est ce
que des pays qui ne vaccinent toujours
pas sur les 47 pays que nous pouvons
ainsi dans les dents dans notre région
ils ont tous actuellement sont tous
actuellement en cours de processus de
vaccination et assurent ses 47 pays là
on a pratiquement juste une dizaine qui
n'ont pas encore bénéficié de ce que
l'on appelle ce mécanisme de kovacs qui
est ce mécanisme est un peu
multinationales dont qui permet vraiment
aux pays qui ont des ressources limitées
donc de pouvoir s'approvisionner en
vaccins mais bénéficie aussi d'autres à
d'autres à d'autres canaux donc avec les
accords bilatéraux avec certains pays
mais sinon la vaccination et les encours
on parle de jours du 2 millions de
personnes qui sont vaccinées dans la
région et pour finir peut-être juste
vous dire par exemple
allez les dernières éditions du
mécanisme popovac ce visage de pouvoir
vacciner
donc voilà on sait qu'il ya quand même
des problèmes d'approvisionnement ce qui
ralentit forcément les campagnes de
vaccination c'est un peu le cas partout
dans le monde
il ya aussi le scepticisme vis-à-vis de
certains vaccins notamment le vaccin
astrazeneca est ce que c'est le cas
aussi parmi les populations africaines
oui absolument je pense qu'il ya vous
avez évoqué deux enjeux qui sont très
importants il ya le processus
d'approvisionnement donc des vaccins
d'acquisition des vaccins et
l'acceptation de ces communautés là et
où absolument donc l'organisation
mondiale de la santé le bureau régional
de l oms ici en afrique travail très
très fort donc pour pouvoir avec les
états membres donc pour pouvoir adresser
ces deux enjeux là sur le premier comme
je vous disais là le mécanisme de kovacs
par exemple aujourd'hui il est en cours
il ya une certaine solidarité donc entre
les pieds qui s'est organisée donc avec
donc un certain partage des doses de
vaccins dont qui sont pour et qui va
certainement augmenter
évidemment la situation and end avec
l'interruption un peu de
l'approvisionnement des pays acp les
autres pays à l'imiter sûr c'est cet
approvisionnement la a mais des
discussions sont en cours je pense pour
pouvoir trouver dans des solutions à
cette situation
l'afrique du sud va l'afrique du sud
pardon a écarté le vaccin sera zeneca
après une étude qui a révélé une
efficacité limitée sur son variant le
pays a donc misé sur johnson & johnson
est ce que l' oms recommande vivement
astrazeneca dans les pays africains sous
quelles conditions
mais absolument donc le astrazeneca en
fête a été validée comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure par un comité
d'experts parle expertise nécessaire
donc pour pouvoir aller de l'avant et ce
vaccin là jusqu'à preuve du contraire
donc il est fortement courage être
utilisées donc dans tous les pays y
compris en afrique du sud dans une
certaine mesure mais maintenant une
combinaison évidemment de beaucoup
d'autres vaccins peut toujours permettre
donc d'adresser les enjeux qu'ils
peuvent
qui peuvent apparaître avec de ces
mutations qui sont continuées qui sont
naturels donc l'om est définitivement
encouragent vraiment la multiplication
de ces vaccins là pour pouvoir avoir
plus d'efficacité sur tous les types de
valiant le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement y compris au sein du
système qu'au vaccin sur
l'approvisionnement est ce que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent pensée ou et où est le
mécanisme de la vaccination vous savez
ça a soulevé beaucoup d'enjeux sur la
question de la solidarité beaucoup de
travail a été fait sur sa ou des
derniers mois à la l'enjeu principal
qu'on a vu c'est un peu à cette
aggravation de la situation en inde
donc il ya qui a fait que l'inde est
l'une des organisations et des
entreprises donc ils préparés et qu'ils
fournissent et ses vaccins là a dû
limiter dans cette fourniture delà de
ces vaccins dans certains pays mais
sinon le mécanisme il est en cours je
prends cette solidarité l'année en cours
actuellement et à la problématique de
l'approvisionnement est quand même
antérieur à la situation que l'on
observe aujourd'hui en hollande
non non c'est sûr c'est sûr absolument
il est il et il est fort à noter que
tous les besoins ne sont pas couverts
dans la région ici donc mais ce travail
qui a été un houblon qui a été initiée
par les plus hautes autorités donc
autant dans les pays au niveau par
exemple de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé pour faciliter à quartz et
solidarité là et que nous encourageons
aussi aller de l'avant donc c'est sûr et
certain que les défis et les besoins
sont encore là donc plus si on peut en
faire plus en terme de solidarité de
partage
c'est quelque chose vous savez que la
solidarité vaccinale elle ne s'arrête
pas seulement aux systèmes kovacs au
sénégal au botswana en république
démocratique du congo seychelles on se
tourne vers le vaccin chinois sinopharm
l'algérie l'egypte et la guinée vers le
vaccin spoutnik vais le vaccin russe
quelles sont les recommandations de l
oms vis-à-vis de ce que certains
qualifieront peut-être de diplomatie des
vaccins et d'autres tout simplement de
solidarité en matière de lutte contre le
coc vide
même en dehors du système kovacs
oui comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure
c'est sûr qu'on a un mécanisme qu'on a
mis en place le kovacs met à portée de
ce mécanisme là il ya les accords
bilatéraux que les états membres d'un
signe avec certains pays avec certaines
organisations donc la priorité est
évidemment pour l'organisation mondiale
de la santé c'est de pouvoir adresser
les besoins de santé donc des
différentes populations
ces deux éléments importants et comme je
le disais tout à l'heure à voir donc
tous ces différents vaccins cela nous
permet un peu d'adressé beaucoup de
challenges auxquels on peut faire face
absolument et je dois aussi à ce
mécanisme actuellement qui ont cours
actuellement d'homologation ada2 des
vaccins des candidats vaccins dont on
parlait par exemple de sinofert ou bien
de synovate
c'est des choses qui vont arriver assez
rapidement donc c'est des éléments tout
ça c'est des éléments prometteurs je
pense pour pouvoir avoir suffisamment de
bienne goods si je peux dire comme ça
pour pouvoir donc adressé ses besoins
donc ces besoins qui sont très très
importants y compris leur accent russe à
ce pique-niqué absolument aussi je pense
aussi ce processus d'homologation aussi
il est en cours d'évaluation d'analysé
ou aussi et je suis convaincu que tout
la disponibilisation de tous ces
différents vaccins leur permettra d'être
beaucoup plus sur le ms a exhorté
certains pays africains à ne pas
détruire les vaccins anti qu'ovide péri
mais c'était en avril dernier
à charge pour les autorités nationales
de réglementation des médicaments de
trancher sur leur utilisation après la
date de péremption
expliquez-nous cette démarche parce que
vous savez que dans beaucoup de pays
européens en france par exemple on jette
quotidiennement des doses non utilisées
le jour même oui absolument mais quand
plan si la disponibilité des vaccins là
dans nos différents pays
donc la recommandation de leur céder le
pouvoir ne pas les utiliser de les
mettre sur place
et comme la science et les volumes les
choses on les découvre donc au fur et à
mesure donc de voir s'il ya des
changements qui peuvent être apportées
pour pointer serment donc la durée de la
date donc d'utilisation de ces vaccins
là donc c'est dans cette logique là un
peu pragmatique et de pouvoir donc se
donner une chance peut-être une chance à
la science de tous les plus
d'informations sur l'efficacité des
vaccins
la date initiale de péremption donc
c'est vraiment c'était logique
il faut prendre une vaccination low cost
en afrique lors une vaccination reste
une vaccination savez la vaccination ce
n'est pas elle n'a pas commencé avec la
vida donc là on vienne par exemple
aujourd'hui de d'éradiquer un peu le
virus de la poliomyélite sauvage en a
fait à travers la vaccination il ya
beaucoup de processus de vaccination qui
sont en cours pour que le choléra contre
l'ebola donc ce n'est pas quelque chose
de vous probablement pour la population
en général c'est la première fois qu'ils
en entend beaucoup parler mais sinon
c'est une mesure majeure de santé
publique est utilisé de façon régulière
et ce qui est important c'est
l'adaptation parce que on n'a pas encore
toutes les informations sur tous ces
éléments vaccin de les effets de ces
vaccins là et donc pouvoir coupler le
poste de vaccination avec la recherche
qui est en cours nous permettre de faire
des ajustements nécessaires
c'est ça la véritable vous l'avez évoqué
tout à l'heure assez rapidement à quand
un vaccin africains on sait que le
nigeria affirme qu'il élabore son propre
vaccin contre le coc u19 pour en finir
avec justement la dépendance vis-à-vis
des laboratoires étrangers
mais tous ces efforts là son temps que
beaucoup de pays aujourd'hui que ça soit
le sénégal le nigeria l'afrique du sud
beaucoup de pays ont cette ambition là
je pense que pouvoir donc dynamiser la
recherche médicale la recherche
biomédicale dans notre région c'est
quelque chose d'absolument important non
seulement pour pouvoir adresser
véritablement la problématique de
lakovic et toutes les autres
problématiques de santé publique dont
pouvoir amener cet agenda l'agenda de la
santé publique au top quelque part donc
des priorités à des pays des
organisations
c'est quelque chose que nous saluons
énormément au niveau de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé et au rouleau date
pour le vaccin africains à quel horizon
il est difficile de le dire
actuellement il est absolument difficile
de le dire actuellement dans ses
évaluations là sont en cours mais je
suis convaincu qu on aura des nouvelles
à d'aller dans les prochaines périodes
là qui arrive là merci beaucoup à vous
dr thierno
baldé je rappelle que vous êtes le chef
de l'unité partenariats opérationnels au
bureau régional de l oms afrique
merci et merci à vous d'avoir suivi
cette grande interview une grande
interview à retrouver sur nos réseaux
sociaux et notre site
rt france point tva très bientôt
[Musique]